are all words contrast words which is
just a word that i'm giving it which
means to understand the concept of dog
one needs to know what is not a dog some
people say this but i imagine they're
not linguists they're just imprecisely
saying this so if this is the case then
to me then the word everything slash the
universe would have to imply that one
has a conception of what's not included
in everything but then you get some
paradox there because if you have an
understanding of what's not included in
the word everything you can include that
in the word everything so is that true
that to understand a word we do so by
understanding what that word means in
contrast to what it's not
well if we
if
there is nothing that is not a dog then
we don't understand the word dog
the word dog
and every substantive word
if we understand it at all
we understand that some things don't
fall under that concept
actually what a dog is is not a trivial
matter
if you look into it the meaning of the
word dog is quite intricate
it's not a matter of just
picking out an object in the world
independent of our mind that doesn't
work
but
the microphone in front of me is not a
dog
at least that much is clear
with regard to the word
the universe well
we do have a concept of things that are
not in it
like uh
unicorns for example
they're not in the universe
zeus is not in the universe
uh lots of things that we think about
are not in the universe
things we once thought were in the
universe
we now think are not in the universe
plagian for example
there were once
good theories serious scientific
theories
which developed properties of phlegin
we now have different theories which
don't postulate it
so then
we took it to be in the universe now we
take it out of the universe the words
like
all and everything are in a different
category they're not substantive words
so we understand them just by their
logical properties
not with regard to things they exclude
i noticed that you
skipped one was that on purpose or yeah
only because i had a question about when
turing said meaninglessness that if he
was to say so and so is meaningless then
to me
one has to understand meaninglessness in
terms of meaning
and if we're saying well it's
meaningless because we don't have a
great concept of meaning then to me that
would imply we don't have a great
concept of meaninglessness
well what turing was saying
we don't have a clear concept of
thinking
and since we don't have a clear concept
of meaning
there's no point in trying to ask
questions like
can machines think
machine remember maintenance program
and we programs a theory so he's asking
basically
can we have a theory of thinking
well not unless we know what we're
talking about
so in that sense it's meaningless
it doesn't there's no significance to
what we're saying he's using the word
meaningless in the ordinary informal
sense
where some things
just have no significance like asking uh
how many uh
how many
legs does
a unicorn have is
it's not a factual question
we can raise the question if we're
talking about mythology
then we can say four legs but the
question how much how does it many does
it really have